Oh what is going on due to now recently
a subscriber asked you she really in
tune with your feminist art so I was
wondering what's your pigeon home [ __ ]
first off be actually wrong offend me
because I'm from feminine Jen I got like
three Asian nipple chest hairs I say
otherwise y'all ever notice that we can
never really get chest hair but we get
like three random nipple hairs they look
like a racket claw like this but I do
believe that I understand women better
than most men because I grew up in a
beauty supply store and a salon around a
lot of strong-headed women so how do I
feel about women who dress [ __ ] you
already know what it is
LG baby let's get it first off let's
start with this there is nothing wrong
with the woman showing off the sexy side
so hey the [ __ ] dawg hey I appreciate
but here's the thing if you are but ass
making the public and do they looking at
your chimichangas it's not their fault
now crazy women activists calm your
brain image on it down now go get me
wrong no woman on this earth deserves to
be objectified both men and women alike
will be judged based on how they look
and how they carry themselves for
example on the hypocrisy the [ __ ] how
are you gonna be half naked and tell
someone to respect your mind when the
old jetty is flapping now your mind is
not what I'm looking in the [ __ ]
mouth will say my God look at those
tapes [ __ ] must be smart how you go walk
around with your titties all out if
you're mad at a man for looking at it
hmm
that make sense to you let me tell you
something [ __ ] it'd be weird if I didn't
look hi I'm candy pop what's up hi oh my
girl respect me [ __ ] people can know you
from the first encounter well that's
like if you met me I said huh I bet he
doesn't speak any English I wouldn't be
offended
[ __ ] I look forward is fun hey looky
here people's initial opinions about you
are based on your appearance that's how
it is and if you have not figured that
out by now get your [ __ ] life
together
if you conversed and had an intelligent
conversation with the man and he still
objectified you well [ __ ] him then
well don't [ __ ] that would defeat the
purpose you to be honest that's like me
walking into a girl where my twizzler
out and be like hey don't you look at my
dick respect my mind ladies is a natural
and human instinct for us to look at
your Tatas and you know what ladies why
don't you be honest for a second because
you are not letting your monkey twins
hang out like a pair of ripe bananas for
the ladies you know and ladies here's
another thing there's a way to be sexy
and dress sexy without barely covering
you give your penis flat track if all
you got to show yourself hat but Nikki
throughout the whole week then it just
might be safe to assume that you don't
got much to say and here's another thing
if you don't walk around dressed like to
do like you might have a dick in your
pants then don't get mad with these
girls walk away with you man because the
first thing you say and [ __ ] like hello
if I just like a [ __ ] I could get into
but today it ain't happening so I hate
them for it if they choose to dress like
that that's all of them
it should not affect you ladies and
people are like you can not control what
other people do you can only control
what you do
and ladies don't walk around dressed and
do clothes like some creature from the
abyss and it's make me gotta say god
damn girl no you are not nothing save
wardrobe but [ __ ] you hella fire all up
here it is if you dress on the whole
that just might be a chance you might be
treated like a home doesn't mean it's
right probably not does it meet you
alone hail [ __ ] up be happy with who
you are and get comfortable with your
sexuality but do it with some class you
know what when I'm a kid I hope it's a
boy coz if I have a daughter I don't
want to have to deal with all the [ __ ] I
don't want to ask any questions like
daddy what's a hull pump uh-huh baby
that's a farm tool baby go to your moon
[Music]
but there's something about you that's
making this scale like a movie scene
we're trying to get my daily dose of
potassium because bananas have a lot of
potassium it's a sign you know what read
a [ __ ] book I don't know that's some
deep [ __ ]